thank you very much good morning nice to
be with you here in the Italian house on
Columbus Day appropriate somebody's
probably already made the joke we're we
we're going to talk about Chinese
outward direct investment in the United
States here but we're really going to
talk about more than just that issue
because what that is showing us is what
level of maturity Chinese companies are
at that they can now go beyond their own
home court their own home playing field
and it also says something about motive
why given that everybody thinks China is
worth so much of the world growth is
would anybody want to take money out of
China to invest in our old tired senior
citizen markets in Europe in the United
States right but it's happening and so
we're going to talk a little bit about
why I understand we have 30 minutes only
so I'm going to move very quickly my
slides are available to you if you want
to go back and refer to them or if you
maybe already seen them that's fine too
some of them you'll recognize from the
readings I suggested to you so this is
where China is in the world economy
today just to give it sort of some
context about twenty one percent of the
world's people are the people of China
and about you know less than ten percent
shares of global exports and global
imports eight seven and a half date and
half percent their GDP now about nine
percent of global gdp in a few ways
china is much bigger than its weight in
terms of share of foreign exchange
reserves held thirty percent of all the
four exhale down on the planet is held
in beijing Treasuries but in terms of
outward direct investment just three and
a half percent of the world total there
so it's not something that is well
developed in china to date and that's
not unusual for a developing country not
to have a lot of direct investment
assets placed away from home the
difference you understand of course
between portfolio investment and direct
investment portfolio investment you call
your broker and you say buy me some
Treasuries or some guilts well or you
know your issue guilt guilt that in
Britain I believe right so that's
portfolio flows that's
easy direct investment operating a
company in Languedoc or Peoria or
Indiana is it very hard it's not so easy
you have to do more than just call the
broker so that's why it doesn't happen
so much for poor countries that are just
getting started the red line here is
trying to share of global direct an
outbound direct investment which
includes right merger and acquisition
and greenfield both of those can be
direct investments and we see the us
here at the top you know you're
Europeans some new Europeans there in
the middle China until maybe 2006-2007
wasn't even on the map it was virtually
nothing in terms of global direct
investment and now it's maybe five
percent or so four or five percent of
global direct investment three and a
half in the most recent data we have
after 2005-2006 the pattern changes
that's when we start to see China change
it goes from a mirror you know a few
billion dollars a year of outflows to
what we now have about 60 70 billion
dollars a year of direct investment
outflows from China it starts in the
mid-2000s and the reason it starts is
that China found itself horribly under
invested in natural resources so while
this take off starts half a decade ago
in the mid-2000s that was investment
flow almost entirely going into natural
resource operations which harder than
portfolio calling the broker but a lot
easier just to dig stuff out of the
ground as they know how to do very well
in China compared to operating a
white-collar leave you know skilled
labor intensive operation in Paris or
New York or something like that so the
take-off had begun some time back but it
really wasn't coming into markets such
as the United States here's the US the
stock of foreign investment in America
by 2010 two and a half trillion dollars
worth of inward FDI in America that's
not counting investment into financial
institutions which would sort of
overstate the values of bed Europe of
course seventy percent of all the FDI in
America Asia a much smaller
sixteen percent and of eight and of that
China one-third of one percent so while
people start talking about this issue as
though it were so sprite nning the
Chinese are taking over really we have a
very very long way to go before China
catches up to Belgium let alone takes
over the United States right but but the
story is starting to change so I said
after 2005-2006 China takes off starts
to take off to the world but it doesn't
really start going to oecd economies
like the US by 2009 2010 we do see by
some measures it's starting to take off
even into the u.s. from an extremely low
base we're talking tiny amounts of money
compared to portfolio flows are compared
to European investment in the US but
we're no longer but it's a change in
pattern that matters not the amounts
right now this is a statistically
significant change in what's happening
in terms of China's interest in
investing out into economies like the
United States there are important
differences in how we talk about the
numbers so so many different numbers
here whether you just look at what the
official foreign parent is in the
balance of payments data which would be
these light blue lines or you go do the
research to figure out who the ultimate
beneficial owner is seventy percent of
all China's outbound investment
according to their government goes to
Hong Kong and the British Virgin Islands
well guess what that's not the
destination that's the first place you
go so you can obscure the tax and a
profitability and hide it from your
Communist Party you get to keep all the
money if you're a chinese state company
of course the same reason that Enron
went through the Caribbean Sam is white
china goes to Hong Kong so the actual
number is much bigger and as you'll see
in a second when we count up just the
asset side not the net position it's
even much bigger twice as big as these
numbers in fact if we set aside the
liability side of the ledger this is
China's investment picture around the
United States in 2003 I mean it's just
like a single digit number of d
maybe 10 deals total around the United
States by 2007 the picture looked like
this by 2010 the picture look like this
pretty significant change in what's
happening again small numbers to begin
with but there's a new era new phase on
top of us that we need to understand and
already people are starting to debate
this the wrong way very often assuming
that china is only going after
high-technology assets national security
problems this kind of thing when we
start looking into the data our way we
find that the patterns are much
different than what most people are
suggesting let me say something very
briefly about our methodology so most of
the research on this topic uses
balance-of-payments information which is
compiled by the IMF national government
of china national government of the
united states that data is useless for
the hong kong reason i just mentioned
but even when it's good data so on the
US side for example the b oki data is
better but they intentionally don't tell
us which industries how big individual
deals are that's often business
confidential information and it requires
the company your company other companies
reporting most of that which is optional
in many cases to get a clearer picture
so what we did was we went through and
found every single deal that was
announced in each of the past 10 years
and created our own database using the
FBI databases that investment banks use
to get started and then starting to
develop relationships we now have
relationship with 45 out of the 50
American state investment promotion
agencies each state in America is now
actively trying to get chinese to come
and we're talking to those people they
don't want to be the last ones on the
map so they're telling us when a deal
happens so we're starting to get a
different picture it doesn't matter to
us if wenchang automotive which is one
chinese auto sector company in illinois
whether they brought the money from
China or they borrowed the money from
citibank in Chicago the project lending
facility to use to make an acquisition
in America we don't care we want to know
what's the value of Chinese control
assets in this economy and we want to
know what's the value of Chinese
controlled assets in Europe
this study we have coming out in about
four months now five months that's not
the official be Opie way of doing it
you're only looking at money coming in
if you're doing it be Opie you're not
looking at money that could have been
found locally also in the be Opie
balance-of-payments approach if once
when John makes that investment here
they make an intra-company loan back out
to China then that reduces their net FDI
position in America and surprise
surprise that changes the story entirely
of course right so we look at the value
of asset to entered contracted in the
initial acquisition or the initial
greenfield investment once it's begun
and we use those numbers to get a
different picture so when we do that we
get to add a lot of granular information
along the way as we build the base and
we get for example we can see the
difference between ma and greenfield the
green fields here in green the merger
and acquisitions in blue important
things on this sheet our first of all
2008 2009 2010 and now 2011 as well one
hundred and thirty two hundred and forty
percent a year growth teach of these
years so if anybody in Washington thinks
well we will decide whether we're going
to let the Chinese end that's nonsense
it's a conceit they think they're
controlling this lever act the reality
is most of these deals are not going to
be blocked cannot be blocked there's not
going to be any logic to blocking them
so that's first point second point as
Chinese firms are able to do green
fields to a greater extent that we
usually see for developing countries
well that's not a surprise Shanghai is
already an OECD economy it's at the same
level of South Korea basically
competitively speaking right at the same
time you have this very big developing
country that is the rest of China
I'm glad you asked we'll get to that
just a second i'll tell you the best to
the best of my ability anyway we have
the state-by-state breakdown in terms of
amount of investment so texas in the
lead of course texas texas i went to
texas undergrad so makes me happy out of
just under three billion dollars twenty
deals Texas because is big number
because that's where Chesapeake shale
gas and a handful of other big natural
resource and steel deals now too kenjan
steel operating in Galveston likewise
Virginia is that on the top of the chart
because of AES cic investing in aes
right one of your global peers I guess
fair to say yeah New York is large
because of lenovo about corporate
domiciles in in New York Delaware's
higher on the list as well because it's
a corporate domicile so here's the
industry picture to the best of our
ability we've colored pink and blue
between manufacturing and services to
give you a quick sense when you look at
the graph that it's a broad spectrum
it's not just service investments it
used to be just investments in
warehousing operations trade
facilitation offices designed to write
invoices and do fulfillment stuff like
that that's not the case anymore the
higher up you go is the larger amount of
investment so industrial machinery
equipment and tools at the top the
further out this way is the number of
deals so you have lots of sectors that
have smaller deals but more of them of
course right and then the size of the
circle is the average deal size so
that's you guys the big blue dot there
in your space utilities you get larger
transaction size is taking place
although very few of them right hence
its toward that side of the chart we
know if had a es antigen up in
Massachusetts which closed in the second
order interesting because the state that
font on power bought out was bought out
from an Indian company so it was already
held by a brick it just got transferred
to another brick Chinese brick
nonetheless some would have thought the
US would have tried to impede or block
that deal we did not let it go through
every reason we should let it go through
briefly then we can also look at whether
the companies are government control of
Chinese companies or not some amount of
judgment is needed to do this we use a
twenty percent threshold so anything
more than twenty percent Chinese
ownership we call it a government
ownership we caught a government company
less than twenty percent government
ownership we call it a private or
publicly held company hmmm so there's
two categories of direct investment
there's merger and acquisition which
means i buy gdf okay it already exists I
don't the Chinese do right they just did
it already exists they're not creating
they're not building something new
they're acquiring an existing asset
greenfield is I'm bringing money in to
build something from scratch for the
first time that's that's the difference
between breed yeah so we see here in
terms of control that in the term in the
number of deals being done seventy
percent are not government Chinese
companies by the value because the
government is more heavily represented
in the capital intensive industries
sixty-six percent this is the government
related firms making these investments
there's many controversies qua way
telecommunications is a private company
and yet it's being treated in the United
States as though it were government
lenovo is now a private company the
government entity which helped create it
has sold it shares out to american and
other hedge funds over the past years
it's now no longer a government firm and
are in our estimation so the 2011
pattern we see is holding up this growth
you know second highest ever in the
second quarter of 2011 this is the new
normal it's not just one occasional high
quarter from a big deal it's every
quarter is a billion dollars or more
deals and that's you know continuing to
grow in magnitude very quickly this is
the European picture by the way which as
I mentioned we have a new research
project similar to our us work coming
out in about in about four months
and come back and talk about this in a
second this is where the breakdown is in
terms of European flows using our
methodology UK not surprisingly given
London as a deal center at the top
hungry at the top because of a handful
of big industrial transactions similarly
Sweden because of Volvo and a few other
few other deals I thought you might find
this event dressed although you know
more about this and I do we just threw
this into the presentation last week I
haven't my colleague kilo Hanuman put it
together for me this is all deal
activity globally by Chinese investors
in your space and in your business so we
have your gdf at the top here to s power
and Singapore AES and enter gen American
deals i referred to we have some
brazilian investment assets state grid
company typical kind of investor there
as you would have seen in the second
quarter reading second quarter update I
suggested to you we've made some
comments on why we think Chinese are so
attracted by global generating assets
it's because they're they've got lots of
cash in China but the market structure
is so alagappa listing in China there's
nothing they can do with their cash at
home except Biltmore hotels and
restaurants and the government selling
them to stop building hotels and
restaurants and so they're going out and
investing in what they understand which
is the annuity like returns on
generation assets around the world it's
the way it seems to seems to us I'll
finish up here because I know we only
have 10 or 50 m
if you reduce Chinese easier to change
the regulation absolutely and so the
notion you know if the United States is
trying to stop Chinese investment we're
not doing a very good job are we in fact
we're not trying to stop at Chinese
investment there are some here who would
like to do so there's some here who
would like to think we we could not sure
we can and there are many many many
people in China who think that the u.s.
is closed and that's their excuse for
not having much operation outside their
own economy but of course that's just an
excuse they're making the real reason is
they don't know how to operate in France
of the United States because it's very
difficult there are actually tax
obligations there are environmental
obligations there are human resource
obligations there are compliance
obligations that a typical Chinese
company has no understanding of what so
ever so that's the main reason why they
haven't been here yet not the notion
that somehow the United States is not
letting them again
hot way it's a Hong Kong and today so
we're only counting mainland Chinese
ultimate beneficial owners so if that's
better understood as a Chinese company a
PRC company than a Hong Kong company
that we should have it here and please
to the extent that we're smart on this
topic at all which is barely it's
because we interact with business people
who helped us to fine-tune and improve
our snapshots so I hope that we'll have
a dialogue to follow up on this we have
a lot more work we are about to do on
Europe in particular and I'm sure that
some of you could probably make us
prevent us from making some mistakes so
let's let's keep the conversation going
after today but anyway that would
probably be the reason why it that deals
not there yes no not really no we would
treat that as a Hong Kong company we
don't count Hong Kong investments in our
deal flow we could there's a good case
to make but if we did then our numbers
would be more debatable we only want to
know what's the bright red commie number
look like that nobody can argue about
you know maybe it should be bigger
because Hong Kong should be there maybe
Taiwan to be in there too you know you
could make a case but we want to make it
as simple and straightforward as
possible if we're concerned about
Beijing control then let's just look at
the stuff which is you know
incontrovertibly Beijing let me ask well
we have it like an extra five minutes or
so I want to make sure I preserve enough
time to show you everything we've got so
the next big question we need to spend a
minute on is motive why is this
happening now policy there have been a
number of encouragement policies going
back over the past 15 years or more for
Chinese firms to go abroad none of them
correlated with a take off in outbound
investment except most recently we've
seen this happen so I would say that
policy is important policy can say no
and make it hard for companies to go
abroad but policy cannot make Chinese
companies go abroad unless there's a
clear profit motive
that companies can identify they're not
going to do it even state-owned
enterprises we have tracked state-owned
oil companies of China refusing to bring
oil home from the Sudan when there's not
a high enough pump price for gasoline in
China so if global barrel prices are
higher than the recovery on refining for
petrol and diesel then PetroChina will
make up excuses about refineries being
down and they'll sell the oil to the
Koreans and the Japanese even when
they're ordered by the central
government to bring it back so that's
typical Chinese SOE behavior and they're
not going to go try to invest in America
unless they can be clear how to profit
by doing so what is having an effect on
them is this reality this is just kind
of a discussion slide here this is chart
this is the global production chain from
upstream both an upstream technology
resources to manufacturing and assembly
to distribution and retail this is where
China is and the red curve factory to
the world sure enough but where's the
profit margin going profit margins have
been compressed in this manner so that
manufacturing margins are getting
thinner and thinner and thinner and
design and resources as you well know
are getting richer and richer and also
customer value what Steve Jobs perfected
down on that side is terrific business
to be and if you can do it it's not
where the Chinese are so this has
created an incentive for Chinese firms
to move up and down looking for a way to
shorten the time it will take to get out
of the margin squeeze that they're in
that's a powerful force here there's
macroeconomic factors at work structural
factors at work as well from the
changing cost of operation in China here
we just have two considerations people
talk quite a lot about this red line
which is the appreciation of the
renminbi which is changing the light
manufacturing competitiveness of Chinese
firms right and you know that's on this
axis here so if we want to look at it
since you know 2004 or so we've had
against the dollar an effective about
eighteen percent appreciation of remand
big in nominal terms
the blue line is weight cost and since
2000 this is the index this is the axis
that describes the wage costs change two
hundred and fifty percent change in a
decade in wage costs so which one is
more important it depends on the
industry of course how labor-intensive
they are but there's more than just an
exchange rate issue there's labor issues
there's environmental compliance issues
there's whether you can actually do
innovation in China these things are
structurally changing Chinese
competitiveness and creating incentives
to go abroad for the first time in a
real way there's a long list of
controversial deals which did not
succeed in the United States for one
reason or the other and I'm happy to
talk to you about those for a second if
that's what your interest is but i would
say in general that you look at the
committee on foreign investment in the
United States which is the national
entity which screens to see if there
really is a risk the number of Chinese
deals that they have reviewed doesn't
mean they rejected it means they were
viewed is of course small compared to
the number from economies where we get a
lot of investment from having a lot of
review doesn't mean we don't like you
having a lot of review means there's a
lot of investment coming from your
country it's that simple we've had more
trade disputes with Canada than any
other country in the world does that
mean we have a bad relationship with
Canada or does that mean we have a deep
relationship with Canada we have a deep
relationship with Canada so it's part of
success that there's more of these
reviews for security considerations
China is not Canada and there are
national security concerns which are far
greater in the case of China then there
is in the case of Canada I can assure
you however we're allowing deals to go
through in electricity gen and shale gas
and other natural resources and aviation
and aerospace to major deals so far this
year and several more on the way so it's
certainly not the case if we're trying
to keep Chinese out from sectors that we
could make an argument we're not doing a
good job of that because we're actually
not trying to let me stop there and we
have maybe eight eight minutes perhaps
for for discussion eight or eight or ten
minutes unless I've covered everything
and there's nothing left to discuss one
of the secrets to a chocolate investment
politicians welcome the political
environment in the United States right
so at the state level it's quite pot
it's getting quite positive i would say
there's a serious effort on in almost
all the states now to promote themselves
and market themselves as destinations
for investment so much so that they're
starting to become some tax competition
problems alabama and arkansas have had a
little mini war a little little Civil
War down there over tax breaks offered
to try to get chinese investors in for
example at the national level people are
still trying to play the china card as a
scary thing yeah a romney did it in the
debates so far it's starting to happen
in the campaign but really it's not
happening that aggressively as you think
in terms of the political campaigning i
think certainly we're going to continue
to see the Congress trying to get in the
way of deals trying to block deals we're
going to see the defense community in
the intelligence community make as much
trouble as they can in some sectors for
example telecommunications with Huawei
having a horrible problem but at the
same time the numbers speak for
themselves 130 hundred and forty percent
of your growth and inflows you know look
that that that map of the state's
getting redder and redder and redder as
deals pile up and deals pile up it's
getting a little less frightening I
would say so I think the politics you
know are going to continue to be highly
problematic in some sectors
telecommunication in particular but the
story at the same time is going to be
one of more and more deals happening
successfully
that's a good question and of course
under us inward investment policy the
only thing we're looking for is national
security what the economic implications
are is really not supposed to be a
consideration at all and for the most
part our system does work blind to what
the competitiveness implications are
unless there's some strategic issue that
connects to it in terms of how the
Chinese are operating here so far it's I
think a little too soon to tell after
all this whole database that we have is
about 320 deals now or so so we can't
necessarily draw too many conclusions
from that Chinese government is telling
their companies to use foreign partners
to do jv's not to try to do things
hundred percent for the most part
because they need the skills they need
the local know how I've talked to people
at many of the Human Resources
consultancies like Mercer group is one
that operates here and they used to have
an impossible time trying to get Chinese
clients firms to buy their services to
do a HR strategy for a US investment now
it's not so hard anymore a number of the
deals in this database after they bought
acquired a u.s. going concern all the
management left because they said well
you know the Chinese on this company now
it's not going to be the right place to
work we're going to go someplace else to
work and they could do that if they
started the company they just got their
10 million dollars or 50 million or
whatever and then they took the money
and left and the business failed or
close to failed afterwards because the
Chinese didn't know how to run it in the
US so they started understanding they
have to offer retention packages to keep
management in place after they make an
acquisition so Jay being retention
strategies worked out with consultants
and advisors these things are starting
to show up after the initial wave of
sort of mixed experience i would say in
some of the deals for example
chesapeake deals interestingly scenic
has sort of intentionally not put
technicians into those operations in the
united states because they didn't want
to create the appearance that they were
just here to grab some shale gas
fracking technology and take it home
they're going slow in terms of moving in
Chinese technicians and engineers
depends on the politics I think and the
advice they're getting from their
advisors whether that would be the case
in any particular deal
hahaha the link is the deep rich
potential of the mature economies you
asked me about the United States I'll
talk about the US when we could say the
same thing about Europe until presently
the number of invention patents filed by
all Chinese companies every year is
fewer than the number of invention
patents every year from the state of
Vermont from the state of Vermont
there's lots of junk patents being filed
now patents that aren't really major
innovations from China but in terms of
real innovative potential and capacity
there is so much potential in the US in
Western Europe in Japan the problem is
if is the demand future demand there to
justify all the sinking of costs up
front to make use of those assets that
research potential and capacity I think
and that's another question may be the
one that bubala was talking about a
little bit you know but for the time
being just how fertile the soil here is
that terroir if you will of the American
economy is just incredibly incredibly
valuable especially for its
complementary to what China has China
has the low labor costs it has the
demand potential for the future it has a
lot of capital even what it doesn't have
is a lot of process know how human
capital sophistication innovative
experience and so that's bringing
Chinese students to Colombia because
they think that just by being here
somehow they'll they'll get that now i
have many in my class here and i'm not
so sure and they have a hard time with
my tests because they they answer the
question the same way is set it in the
textbook but I get a C+ or something
like that and they're very upset I said
no I didn't want you to copy out of the
book I wanted you to analyze and tell me
what you thought this meant you know and
that's just an alien concept so you know
we have one of one of life's life's
you know compensation for getting old is
you get wiser hopefully and you have
some assets that can be put to work even
when you can't run as fast as you could
when you were at China's level of
economic development so one more
question perhaps or or not well I do
hope that a few people from the group
with an interest in this topic will get
my email these are from the slides or
otherwise and maybe we could have a
little dialogue I'd very much like to
send you if you don't already have it
the table of global investments in this
space in your space a generation and
have a little back and forth with you to
see if there's some additional value we
can squeeze out the connection with each
other so with that okay